I want to say thank you to the World
Economic Forum for the opportunity to be
here this morning and to discuss with
from each Audrey Erica our relationship
between India and the United States
which is growing obviously the focus
many of the comments today was on the
continuity of the relationship under a
second Obama term and I think we are
looking very very much forward to seeing
India continue to expand its global role
whether it's in the field of strategic
importance or on economic side I see our
own relationship as expanding greatly in
our 23 dialogues but in addition to that
are very very important people to people
interaction whether it's commercial
transactions well there's students in
both countries visiting the other
country to study or are individuals who
are in contact with each other I think
we touched on a number of key issues
today looking forward to expanding our
trade and going over the hundred billion
dollars in goods and services that go in
both directions and benefit both of our
countries we're looking forward to an
expanded dialogue season we've just
completed an energy dialogue in a
strategic dialogue we will be looking at
other fields and we'll have particularly
focus on energy this month as our state
Department energy person comes to India
I want to thank you again for this
opportunity to be here and wish you all
the best